Stanford University so about 25 years
ago I get seriously interested in the
question of why did these new graduate
students coming into my physics research
lab how could they have done so well for
so many years in physics versus and not
be able to do physics and that led me to
first learn about and then participate
in really a new way of thinking about
science teaching and learning and this
is really the idea of approaching it
like a science and so that we we do
controlled experiments looking at
different ways of teaching and measuring
the learning that's produced between
them and figuring out then what works
and why based on data where we're
judging what works on how much students
are actually learning now this is a area
of research primarily carried out in
undergraduate science courses it was
started in physics 30 or 40 years ago
and has now spread across all the
sciences and we see quite similar
results across them and one of the
things we found is the most revealing
measures of learning are to look at
situations where a simple relevant
context as a topic you're trying to
teach and have a look at what scientists
can do when posed with this question
what predictions they make and why and
then you ask students to do the same
thing and you compare the responses
clearly you often see big differences
but this is really the measure of but I
don't argue is sort of flexible useful
knowledge how well you can apply it in
in in relevant situations and we get
very different results when we compare
that measures with what people see from
the U
of course exams which appear to be
primarily testing if students have
memorized certain facts and procedures
that are aren't good for too much beyond
passing their physics course
so using these managers of learning we
then go out and and like i say do
compared experiments and since most
classes are being taught with lectures
we compare those where the students are
spending their time listening the
instructors are mostly telling them
things with various kinds of what i'd
call sort of scientific teaching where
as we've evolved over time different
ways the instructor the students are are
practicing and and doing activities and
this and the instructors are coaching
and we're not just comparing with
lectures like this we're comparing with
ones with very charismatic engaging
lectures surprisingly it does not matter
very much and the results and there's
many many results now published on this
and i'm going to give you a few examples
so in this this is one study i was
involved with and if it was looking at
directly the amount of learning really
produced in the classroom and so we had
two big sections of introductory physics
where we carefully measured they were
very nearly identical in all respects
they were cut the two instructors were
covering the same set of learning
objectives and exactly the same amount
of class time a week of lectures and
then right at the end of that both were
given sections were given this the same
test that covered those objectives and
the comparison here was the the first
class was taught by someone was a very
experienced teacher of this material had
good student evaluations ratings and so
by the current university standards of
this and any other university would be
considered a good teacher and the other
section was was taught by someone who
was a fresh PhD in physics but had been
trained
the program I ran and these methods and
practices of scientific teaching and so
how did they do and the on the common
test at the end well you can see here
this is the this is plotting the number
of students versus their test score
random guessing would give you three and
you can see a profound difference in the
distribution between these two classes
really the the entire distribution in
the class has moved up and with of
course the experience traditional
lecture being much far below here's a
now that was just learning in the
classroom here's an example which is
looking at an entire course and also not
comparing two different instructors but
comparing the same instructors just
they're using different teaching methods
and so this has work done at Cal Poly
they looked at the concepts of force and
motion covered in this in this course
and how well students could apply these
two simple situations like a physicist
would they there's a good test for this
you use pre and post measures of how
much learning gain the students get from
class they collected data for many years
as that as these instructors were using
traditional instruction and they were
getting gains of about point three
that's we have lots of data from physics
that's pretty good for a good lecture
instruction and then they all the
instructors switched over to this
scientific teaching approach and
basically everyone jumped way up you can
see up here they're now fairly
consistent with much better learning
about a factor of two on average now the
thing I want to emphasize these are the
same people the same instructors the
only thing they changed where the
teaching methods they used and you get
greatly improved learning as a result
and you can just how great this is I
mean most I'm are bad a factor to this
person their students are learning six
times more than they were before they
chance to these scientific
methods finally this is this is not
looking at learning this is looking at
failure rates this has work done by in
computer science by best Simon who
worked with me for a while went back to
UCSD and got the instructors there to
change their teaching approaches for
these core computer science courses and
as a result after they changed over the
failure rates dropped dramatically
across all of these courses and so again
we have the same instructors just using
new teaching methods and getting much
greater student success about 1/3 the
failure rates they had before so you
probably were asked wondering at this
point you know what's actually happening
in these classes and I know I don't have
time to go into detail but basically
instead of sitting listening students
are doing tasks and so for example a
physics class on electricity would start
out with this question for all the
students this circuit with batteries and
light bulbs here and closing this switch
what's happened to the brightness of
that bulb the students are given the
task of answering individually and then
they have to discuss with their
neighbors in the class and come up with
the reason the answer and the reasons
behind it and meanwhile the instructor
like this one is circulating around
they're listening in on those
conversations maybe briefly intervening
and most importantly they're then at the
end of this question leading a follow-up
discussion where they explored the
students different reasoning processes
and give them guidance as to how to go
forward and switching topics slightly
one of the areas I've been working in is
is how we can use technology to support
this kind of of learning by students and
so in this particular class we wouldn't
just give them the answer they'd have to
build this circuit themselves using this
interactive simulations and they would
hook this up they see but the electron
cartoon electrons are doing they close
this
which and they see what happens to the
electrons and the lightbulbs and this
really allows them to do further on
their own exploration and testing and so
on and and this is a project developing
these simulations something I started a
number of years ago and it's I guess
they're gonna be used about a hundred
million times this year so it's getting
to be a fairly big deal that one of the
things I'm really interested in it as a
researcher is that these simulations let
us explore a different area of teaching
and learning than what people been able
to look at with other educational
approaches namely we can have how people
go and discover things how they figure
out things they don't know which they
can do in a simulation and it's very
hard to test that otherwise and so
really looking in their strategies for
discovery and so and our goal is really
to have people develop better
investigation processes just to give you
an idea of how one can use these kind of
things in a real course this is just an
example of the class I'm teaching now a
sophomore level quantum physics course
and they're the students I give them
this interactive simulation of a laser
and how a laser works is a very complex
process a lot of quantum physics in it
and these students are told of figured
out and they can't do it at first but
after about 20 minutes working together
in glass with a little coaching
they are successfully they're successful
in really understanding and quite a lot
of detail how a laser works and this is
only made possible by this technology
usually students really can't learn
ideas of lasers until they get much more
advanced in their academic career and of
course everybody should know about how
lasers work so if I sort of step back
all of this reasons combined it's sort
of demonstrating a fairly fundamental
principle which is that the effective
learning of science it really requires
the per
to be practicing that desired thinking
processes and getting guiding feedback
on them as they do that now and that
means when the key elements is having
carefully designed tasks that get them
to practice that you can use in
classrooms and a lot of what the ongoing
research in this field now has moved to
is really thinking about what is the
best design tasks for particular
subjects in particular areas and what's
the most effective feedback that you can
give that to have students learn most
effectively and efficiently and how does
this depend on students students
individual characteristics and then as I
mentioned we're also looking at ways we
can have technology to support this
particular learning process now a lot of
people running well how broadly does
this apply I think I can say with quite
a bit of confidence and that I'm pretty
certain that a the same basic approach
applies to other subjects and other
levels we just don't have data where
people have actually done the
comparative experiments they are to say
we do have some data from k12 it turns
out there's a there's a number of
complications in both the implementation
and actually carrying out the research
on the effectiveness there so so we
don't have as nearly is not clean and
nice of data as we have from
undergraduate classrooms but what we
have since yeah the basic ideas will
still work the same so from one
perspective you know the idea this is a
better weighted more effective way to
teach is people it's really obvious you
know if you want somebody to learn how
to play basketball you don't have them
sit every day in front of a blackboard
and be told how to play basketball you
have a break it down into particular
skills and practice those skills and get
feedback on them and from another
perspective it's it's completely
consistent and supported by a lot of
cognitive science research about how
people learn to think more like you know
experts and
science scientific reasoning and it
connects up well with the kind of work
that Bruce was talking about and the
kind of work that that Carol talks about
when you get into the details what the
people have to do to learn all of these
things show up in a very consistent
fashion but from another perspective
this is a shocking and unbelievable
result and that is you know universities
like this one and everywhere else are
filled with you know faculty giving
lectures on students about telling them
about science and they're really sure
the students must be learning from these
and they can't imagine any other way to
teach it and if we didn't have faculty
like this we wouldn't have been able to
do that experiment like I showed you at
the beginning where wait so so anyway
and you know in summary this kind of
scientific approach of carefully
measuring things and learning and
teaching it's giving dramatic results
and it's giving us important new
insights and ways we can dramatically
improve learning but you know at the
same time it's a little slow to move
from the the research into the college
classroom and to finish with a medical
analogy you know it's what we really
have is that a lot of science faculty
are really using the pedagogical
equivalent to bloodletting when they've
got you know well tested penicillin
sitting on the shelf so we we have a
ways to go but we will get there you
know you you just kind of have to
remember that if you're trying to change
a thousand-year-old tradition it does
take time even if you have science on
your side thank you
for more please visit us at stanford.edu